[Music]
okay Wow I mean thank you by the way to
json' for you for having me here it's an
absolute privilege to be at the last Jay
s confit you of its time so can you guys
just give it up for Jess come for you
cuz like it's been an absolute I can't
believe it
I cannot believe it so you know biggest
JavaScript conference in Europe I think
probably biggest jobs good conference in
the world gonna be talking about
building a jet engine
yeah it was like no pressure at all you
know it'd be completely fine
I should probably introduce myself so
I'm Jason Williams I'm a senior software
engineer at Bloomberg in the UK in
London dare I say Europe and we're still
clinging on we're still clinky gone and
basically I used to also work at the BBC
for a few years as well some BBC people
here and I've also been involved in sort
of tc39 so I've been working on the
promised all settled proposal over the
past year and that basically allows you
to get the result of all of your
promises regardless of their state's
whether they fulfilled or rejected and
then it's up to you you have the control
then to sort of do what you want with
them on their side so I've also been
involved in rust as well I used to be
the maintainer of the sublime text rust
plugin I've handed that over since but
then I since and I've moved into sort of
like the rust dev tools team and they
focus on sort of ID plugins tooling and
then the rust language server as well
which is pretty cool that's basically a
single process they're handles things
like debugging and and hinting and then
all the editors can make use of that so
I thought you know doing some sort of
specifications with JavaScript really
interesting you know working a little
bit on rust as well my two favorite
things how can I marry these two things
together you know might might might my
two my two languages that I love so much
how can i how can I bring these together
and by the way biggest JavaScript
conference in the world I know it's a
ballsy move coming here and talking
about rust but I'm just going to go over
it so bear with me
I thought why not build a JavaScript
engine ridden in Rus you know take the
sort of fun and easy accessibility of
JavaScript and then power that with rust
and then see what we can get it was a
bit ambitious it was quite challenging I
actually started off by looking for a
place where I could contribute to this
nowhere existed like no one actually
built one in Rus before at least two
years ago anyway there was one single
project called I think it was called Jay
s RS and the maintainer basically sort
of abandoned it and it was like six
years old and I tried to build it and
there was like 650 errors and it it was
basically because he he made it at a
time when rust wasn't 1.0 and so the
syntax have changed and moved on and it
was literally faster to just build one
from scratch than it was to try and get
this working so that's exactly what I
did I just thought let's give it a go
I'm not an expert by the way in pausing
or writing compilers or any of that I
mean I even struggle to meet CSS in the
morning so I'm not exactly an expert in
parsing source code or anything my lab
but I thought let's start somewhere I
also realize it was a bit of a jump I
was doing very small things in rust and
going from like hello world to full-on
job sucked interpreter was probably a
bit of a job it just reminded me of the
owl picture I probably should have done
something in between like had to do MVC
or something like that but I knew I had
I knew I was on to something here but I
had a good language oh I knew I had
somewhat good to work with and of a
couple of reasons why I wanted to use
muster to build this engine one was
control so one of the things I process
to you is we're going to give you all
the control you can have plus all the
safety and so I can utilize the sort of
close to the metal nuts of rust and and
do all the things I need to do and then
the compile time checks means that I
don't really fall over myself
it was quite fast so it's built on top
of LLVM and that means that all of the
years of the LLVM compiler optimizations
that they've done Russ can sort of tap
into that and make use of it sometimes
you can even get faster code gem than
clang which produces C
there's some memory safety as well so
rust has a ownership system which is
quite unique so basically if he was
passing the value into a function the
function is now the owner of that value
and so they can only ever be one owner
to a value and that means that when rust
wants to get rid of data it can do so
100 percent confidence because nothing
else is pointing to that thing so you
don't really have dangling pointers or
or seg faults or anything like that
and that leaves really nicely done into
concurrency I might want to make use of
this at some point especially all our
implements a workers or things like that
again because of the ownership model I
won't have to worry too much about
multiple threads trying to access the
same value and then won't need to worry
about databases all of that is taken
care of at compile time which means that
the runtime I'm not penalized on
performance so 40s is a good start you
know let's get going so I started about
two years ago I started I made a git
repo off and gives an engine called boa
someone asked me yesterday why'd you
call it boa I just I went to Australia
in the zoo I saw a really evil boa in
the reptile I thought I'm naming my
jeaious engine after that that is an
evil thing and so I'm gonna have a
high-level view here so the architecture
that I'm gonna go with for now there's
gonna be a few things missing for those
of you who are familiar with compilers
but the view I'm going to start with is
taking some source code and that can be
from say a network or in this case just
reading from a file basically taking the
source code bringing it in as a string
buffer so just imagine a big string of
JavaScript and I'm gonna use the scanner
that I've made to break that down into
some various tokens and these tokens
they're basically like groups of
characters that are bunched together to
have some sort of semantic meaning so in
this case we've got function as a token
or foo or the opening parenthesis here
and we're going to generate a few of
those and we're going to put them into
an array and then we're going to send
them on to the parser operation and the
pars was then going to tapes with those
tokens and it's going to produce
expressions
and these expressions are a little bit
different so expressions can hold other
expressions so for instance if you got
the opening of a function then we have
what we call a function expression or
function declaration and then the block
inside of that function we've got some
variable declaration so the variable
declarations would be children to that
function that's generally the idea so
let's just step into that a little bit
closer
we'll take its line of days here so let
conf equals Dreskin for you I showed
this to someone earlier and they were
like you should have used Const
so sorry sorry I forgot
right but we're gonna start with let's
so imagine that we're scanning this so
that so that thing that reads the file
has done its job now and it's gonna pass
this through I'm gonna start scanning
this so the first one going to be
sitting on is the led and we will
produce a token from that and a token in
this case is just our object and we've
got the value because you want to keep
hold of the value that's quite useful we
want to make some sort of category for
the token in this case it's a keyword
and the reason I know that keyword
because I took a look up on the spec
grabbed the list of keywords and then
basically codified against that and so
when I take a string like let that's got
no sort of quotes at the beginning I
know that it's either going to be an
identifier or maybe even a token and so
what I sought by doing is I check
against my list of list of keywords and
I know that this one is a keyword
because it's not which can't we do the
same thing except kampf
doesn't exist sort of as a keyword so we
just assume it's an identifier but as
you can see we sort of keeping track of
the position the compiler doesn't really
need that per se but it's good if you're
debugging and you can output that there
was a problem on this line or if there's
a token we're not expecting we can say
there wasn't it there was an issue here
and it's on this column this line number
punctuation gets its own category again
we want to keep the value and then where
we are and so on
so here we've got some punctuation a
string and identifier and a keyword and
we're gonna place this into an array and
then pass it on to our puzzle this makes
it easier to deal with when we're
traversing through the source code and
if you just want to look at different
rough don't worry too much about
understanding the syntax or anything
like that
but I make use of rust pattern matching
so think of like switch-case it's very
similar but it's a little bit more
powerful and the idea is that you can
take a character or anything actually
and then the pattern matching allows you
to do some deep structuring on that you
can say is that this or this you can
actually do bindings which I don't have
an example right here or we can just say
is it a digit or is the alphabetic in
this case we want to let so it's a its
alphabetic so we go into a state of
trying to parse and identify it and then
we just take this and put it in a loop
and then we go through each character in
our source code and then do the same
thing and for each character we land on
that's a state so got a little bit of
state machine going on if you want a
quote then we're now in the state of
pausing the string if we want a
character we're in a state of pausing an
identifier or keyword and so on so I've
got a demo this is something I did
earlier I was gonna do it live but Paul
Irish is around so I just wanted to make
sure you know that is not gonna get
interference wave but this is a very
quick sort of writing Kant's conf equals
conf and then we're gonna output some
tokens it's very quick I know there we
go very similar to what I showed you
earlier we have keywords that we have an
identifier and a punctuation etc so this
is not ready to go we're done in this
area we're pausing we're gonna sort of
take that array of tokens and we're
going to try to build a sort of tree
structure now so we're gonna start
building expressions from these tokens
and the way we do that is very similar
to how we were iterating for the tokens
as well so with the tote with the
characters we had a some pattern
matching going on
we do the same thing this time though
we're able to pattern match on tokens so
now we can say we're sitting on the
token that's representing a keyword or
representing an identifier and if it's a
keyword we can say this is also the
keyword that we're currently sitting on
and just a quick side note about pattern
matching it's been so successful in
Westerner it's had it's had a lot of
it's not a lot of success that there's
been a there's actually been a proposal
in stage one to sort of bring pattern
matching across into JavaScript so yeah
keep an eye on that in this case here
we're sitting on top of an F and we know
at this point now our next token should
be an open parenthesis so I've made a
utility function here called xpect punk
and that will expect to have a premises
or it'll basically just arrow out to
that way we can then parse our condition
so this is between the parentheses and
we can make an expression there and we
can do the same thing with the if body
and that is the expression underneath
we've got next there and what that does
is that checks if the next token is
there else else is pretty optional as
you all know so we may or may not have
an else if we do then we will pause that
as well and then what we do after that
is we've got sort of three expressions
the condition the body and then
potentially the else and we add those
expressions underneath the if expression
so you can start to see the sort of tree
structure that we've got again don't
worry about don't worry about the syntax
of this but this is basically
implemented using an enum and the
expressions are what we call variants
each variant can hold another expression
so you get this sort of recursive
structure an EF variant holds an
expression which is a condition which is
another expression that might hold other
things the if body and we wrap the else
in an option which basically means we
may or may not have a value there and
it's basically a very safe way of us
checking to say is there an else if not
don't error we just move on and we get a
non value the Box you can see as well so
these are like the types and the box is
basically saying that these are going to
live
on the heat and it will let us it will
manage that for us so take a look at
this vision be I've added a little bit
more code now we just have a sort of let
conf equals JSON for you again I've
added a little bit more around that and
if we start with our function we get a
function declaration expression and as
we work our way down we get a let conf
and that basically generates a let a
declaration expression underneath the
function and there's also a concept
special as well in this case the
constant special is just a literal so
that's basically saying it is a value
that we don't need to evaluate it's
already there and so that is also a
child of the net declaration and the
reason for that is because obviously you
can declare variables without actually
defining what they are in this case
we're defining it so we go down to our f
and we have we have our if expression
which holds a operation a condition of n
and an else and as I said earlier the
else is wrapped in an option and we
didn't really use else in this case so
it just returns an on then we go into
our if body which is the block
expression and we have another net
declaration and then that also has a
constant special underneath that as well
and then the last thing is the return
which gives us the return expression so
the source code that you see on the left
is basically what would generate the
tree we have on the right again not for
demo so if we can run this and then
there we go yeah and so there's a lot
more going on there and that's because I
could only cover so much on one slide
but there's actually even more
expressions so in this case there's a
block expression at the top and that
represents the global scope and you've
got the function declaration underneath
but you kind of get the idea so now
we're gonna try and evaluate the tree
that we've generated
and there's a couple of things that we
need to do and very in mind the idea is
that we want to walk through the tree
and make decisions based on which
expression we land on so in this example
here we've got a net declaration
expression and the jobs in underneath
it's just an example of what that's
generated and so on the right we've got
the sort of Russ code and what I decided
to do was to represent JavaScript values
in an enum and so we've got all the sort
of values that you can have on the
right-hand side symbol is missing the
pr's are welcome you know but we've got
no undefined Burien string number
integer object and function some people
probably wondering why we have integer
if all numbers are 64 64 bit floating
points if you're doing stuff around
bitwise operations we need to convert
them to a number do the operation on
that and then convert it back into a
floating point so it's kind of used
internally then we take a value and we
wrap it in a GC so there's a really
great GC library that somebody made and
it was super useful and the reason I
needed die is because in JavaScript you
can reference one value for multiple
functions and so that value goes out of
scope you need to make sure that this
stays alive and so the idea here is I
can take a value that I've made put it
in the GC and that GC will automatically
handle not garbage collecting that until
nothing else needs it or at least until
it goes out of scope and nothing else
can possibly point to it so Manish who
worked on that I don't know if he's here
this weekend but he did a really great
job on that and I can just basically add
that in and at the bottom the bottom
line is me generating that so I have my
value data which is a string and I pass
my string in and I now have my value so
this is great
we need to put the value somewhere so I
started off by just using hash flaps so
basically the idea was I had a very sort
of naive approach which was whenever we
come across the function create a hash
map everything inside that function I'll
just throw in there this was just to get
going it surprisingly got me pretty far
but as you saw the tree earlier every
time I stepped onto a function
declaration I would generate a hash map
and then I would start using that and
set my current environment to be that
hash mark and then all I would do after
that is every time I came across a net
declaration I would just add the value
straight in now obviously real engines
do a lot more than this but if you just
want to get going it was pretty
effective you can see here though that
very quickly it's it starts to fail
because we have B here that's in the
same environment as the conf and the B
should probably be removed once that
block expression finishes so I realized
I probably do need to have more
environments than just the one for
function
took a look at the spec a specification
actually points out five of them and it
calls and records I'm not gonna read
them out but you kind of get the idea
and so I then took the environment
section of the spec and basically
implemented that it was not easy it was
not easy at all
but basically what I do now is I create
function records I created block scope
records global scope records and even
module records and then the idea is that
every time I made a new record I'd add
some extra metadata to say what record
it is so I knew where to add the value
and I'd also give it a parent property
as well so though I could point to the
record that I made previously and then
you start to have a sort of chain the
scope chain where we can do I look ups
so we go back to our tree the idea was I
here function declaration I make a
function environment I have a let I have
a declaration I add my value in there
have a block expression I make a
decorative environment add my value in
there so far so good return is
interesting because the Kampf is not
actually in the current environment I've
just made and so I have to make use of
the parent property to do a lookup so in
this case I'm trying to find where
confidence I say to my environment can
you give me the value for Kampf it
doesn't find it it does a lookup into
the function declaration scope and gets
it from there and so this is basically
the scope chain that you've probably
heard obviously people talk about you
can actually put your code into various
tools that show you the tree so there's
a SD Explorer I think it's just a SD
Explorer comm or something but you can
put it on net but you can put your code
in there and you can get a good view of
how it would be expressed as an abstract
syntax tree it's good fun so we've all
of that let's give this a try we've got
our function again very similar to last
time and I'm just gonna console.log it
out
so I implemented console.log which
basically just prints the value of its
given
[Applause]
so there we go and so we have Jay s
configure and that is that thank you
thank you
it's pretty fast as well it's pretty fun
and so yeah they were going buddy
working to begin we've got small things
working then I slowly started adding
some other stuff so I think this week
you know it can do letting Const a bit
better arrow functions are quite easy to
add and once you get the building blocks
there it becomes easier and easier to to
add more stuff a couple of performance
opportunities so one is maybe don't
pause everything most functions that are
declared don't end up even being around
and so it's not worth pausing every
single thing you come across because
that can slow things down
SpiderMonkey and VA they they they do
what's called lazy pausing where they
will come across the function and may
not add it to the syntax tree straight
away but I'll make a note of it and then
pause it just before it's round so it's
all pause lazily and they'll do this
using a pre parser
and that will sort of go and it'll check
through functions but not actually add
them to the ast so that's one Tim don't
pass functions that are going to be
called and all the Jess engines that use
of they will already do this another
opportunity is to make use of the
concurrency and rust so I can actually
break these tasks apart have them run on
separate threads and then pass States
between each of them so we've got a
scanner maybe put on a thread and then
pass the tokens across into the parser
because the scanner doesn't need those
values anymore and it doesn't need to
hold on I can go even further than this
oh I can go even further than this and
have another worker that's reading
through the file and then passing
characters into the scanner so the
scanner can start running before the
whole file is even read and this is
actually something that JavaScript
engines do today it's called script
streaming and the new web assembly
SpiderMonkey engine does this and so as
the script is downloading it can start
running for it straight away and v8 or
so does this as well so a couple of good
things implementing more JavaScript I
need to do that a lot of prototype
methods on there
JIT compilation hopefully gonna be
working with somebody who's got a good
jet package for what's called holy [ __ ]
I like that I'm
hopefully come back and do some more
stuff on the event loop and talk about
it
I've had to leave that out today and
then some more tests around that and
maybe utilizing tests - six - so that's
it I've done it I've bought JavaScript
to the rust ecosystem people in the rust
world can make use of it if they want to
tokenize they can do that it's quite
modular if they want to have a passive
in the rust world they can do it they
can use it they have some jobs with but
and I thought have I married my - my
love of these two things together
I bought Jes into the world of rust can
I bring this piece of rust into the
world of JavaScript yes yes I can
there's web assembly I can bring this
whole thing into the browser I know I
know
the rust team and the web assembly
working group have been working together
for quite awhile now
to make was a really awesome especially
if I reversed they've been working on
some great tooling over the past few
years and why not take advantage about
one of those tools as wasn't buying Jen
and I thought you know what let's take
that and use it with boa and then bring
that into the browser and have people
running Jas JavaScript inception and the
way that that works such a pretty easy
so you take webassembly bring it on to a
place where you want to expose and you
can expose as in the s yes it's module
so something like this basically I've
got a function called evaluate you
passes a string it runs you get a string
back I thought less yeah let's add wise
and bind gender that builds my package
it will generate web assembly and I can
use up there's some of the some
advantages to this it we've quite fast
it's already compiled so when the
browser pulls it in it can just run it
straight away because it's compiled it's
more compact so you've got a faster
download cuz you're downloading less
code there's still the safety aspect
there as well because it still follows
the same rules like same origin and
browser limitation so you don't get this
black box that's making requests where
it shouldn't be and I can expose it to
JavaScript I don't need to rewrite
everything I could just expose this one
thing and use it as though it's just a
J's module even here looks like a jobs
that import it's
actually rust I'm importing there it's
not Jay s I can pass it a string and I
can run it
that's the worsen Biogen attribute you
put that on the top of any function that
you want to expose into the Jay s world
and it will actually build your package
into a wizened file and then you can
import it a little bit like this
let's take a look if I like there we're
gonna build it I'm doing yarn serve
because there's a web assembly plug-in
that's gonna build that out take a look
on the left it's gonna generate a
package folder it's pretty quick I can
make changes to Russ code and that will
run and the browser will reload it's
like I'm writing JavaScript basically
and so now we have a boa bind genoise
zone file and you can import that into
JavaScript so final demo we're gonna
write some j/s we're gonna pass it into
a zoom we're gonna scan it pause it
evaluate it and then we're going to
bring that back into JavaScript and then
what basically print the value out I
don't know try to do some a little bit
challenging over time it'll get more
more challenging but this is the most I
can do right now hopefully we get we can
return hello we can do plus J s cons oh
not to view you you get second function
I never could one bar are you ready
oh come on
Wow that I mean that's what keeps me up
you know that's what get that's this is
why I'm in the industry so a lot of us
are here right that is rust running
there that's no there's no like secret
thing going on there's no network
requests that's rust running in the
browser executes in that j/s scanning it
pause and get evaluating get giving it
back and the jobs kept is still there as
well they work hand in hand so the
takeaway is you can take the Oh
you can take the performance sensitive
parts of your application build them in
something like rust or CN webassembly
and you only need to change those bits
you don't need to change the whole
application but you know the next time
you're thinking of building good you
know J Esparza like this one or game
engine it was super easy and it's worth
doing it's definitely worth thinking
about you can actually play with the
demo as well it is on that github repo
you can actually go there and play with
live it's not perfect and also this the
wesam book and I think some people here
this weekend will be talking about web
assembly as well so hit me up thank you
very much I'm super pleased with that
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]